well not when you consider in Mars
stories how many terrible repercussions
there are from the sexual moment there
seems to be some puritanical ancestral
thing some New England thing maybe I got
it from horth on that sexual pleasure is
sort of disproportionately rewarded with
some kind of calamity but it's always a
part of my purpose as a storyteller to
first create characters that the reader
will be anxious for you can't be anxious
for a character if you don't care about
the character if you don't in some way
like respect or even love the character
or at least have affection for the
character and then once I've established
those characters in whom the reader I
hope has some emotional investment then
it's perversely my job to make as many
terrible things happen to those people
we like as I can imagine six or seven
books ago I might have told you that
maybe I write so much about the things I
fear as a way of hoping that if I write
about these things if I realize them in
fiction that they actually will never
come true and they will never happen to
me but if that were the case it clearly
doesn't work because I'm continuing to
write about the same thing
you